it's very difficult to look at the
current political situation in the
united states and not see that the
country seems to be falling apart there
have been a lot of reasons that have
been proposed for this in the right side
of history my book from a couple of
years ago i proposed that essentially we
had lost a lot of common threads that
bound us together in the social fabric
we lost a lot of the institutions
churches no longer have the same pull
that they once did social organizations
no longer have the same pull that they
once did and we don't have the same sort
of foundational principles and we need
to rebuild those foundational principles
and then there are those who have
suggested that it's due to purely obama
or purely due to trump or maybe it's
just due to the fact that capitalism has
isolated us right that's the argument of
both the left and sort of the
nationalist populist movement there are
a lot of answers that have been provided
but one thing is pretty clear to
everyone and that is political
polarization is now at a modern high and
we've not been this polarized as a
society since at least the 1960s and
maybe more so since the 1960s which
would mean that we haven't been this
polarized probably since the civil war
if you actually look at it statistically
in terms of how many americans really
really really despise each other and
that is what a new poll out of the
university of virginia center for
politics says according to the
politics the new poll shows the
majorities of both trump and biden
voters express support for several
different elements of the bipartisan
infrastructure and reconciliation bills
being debated in congress but more
importantly majorities often large
majorities of both biden and trump
voters express some form of distrust for
voters elected officials and media
sources they associate with the other
side a strong majority of trump voters
see no real difference between democrats
and socialists a strong majority of
biden voters at least somewhat agree
that there is no difference between
republicans and fascists
that's sort of a problem
so the reality is that many of the
things that the democrats are proposing
are not necessarily socialists they're
just big spending social democrat kind
of stuff from northern europe that is
not quite the same thing as complete
nationalization of all resources social
democracy essentially posits that
capitalism ought to provide the basis
for the economy but that we ought to
redistribute a lot of the gains of
capitalism and in certain areas we ought
to nationalize right in certain areas
they are socialistic in certain areas
they are not it's sort of a sliding
scale in other words but the notion that
democrats are like full out nationalize
all industry socialists that's true for
some of them like bernie sanders but it
probably isn't true for the majority of
democrats who at least pay lip service
to the notion that you have a right to
private property and that you should
enjoy most of your rights to private
property and most i would say democrats
other than the squad are still in line
with the notion you should be able to
own a business and you should be able to
reap the benefits of that business at
least to a certain extent and the
arguments are over to what extent and
how strong the regulation should be now
the momentum inside the democratic party
is certainly toward the far left there's
no question about that and the
continuous growth of regulation and
government has has drawn us ever closer
to as frederick hayek would say the road
to serfdom but that does not mean that
all democrats particularly democratic
voters many democratic politicians maybe
most democratic voters are not
socialists and for those on the left who
think that all republicans are fascists
again
you'd have to point to who you think is
a fascist on the right side of the aisle
like an out and out fascist
okay so what the poll shows is that
policy wise there's some commonality
between trump and biden voters but
people look at each other and they
really hate each other which suggests
that more than anything else this is a
culture war this really has less to do
with policy than it has to do with
culture and this is something that i've
been saying for a long time when you
have some of the country that believes
the other half of the country is a bunch
of religious rubes who are obsessed with
their sex lives and who want to control
all aspects of their boudoir
those people tend to treat other people
with a lot of disdain and that's what
you see with the barack obama bitter
clingers comments from 2008 or the
hillary clinton deplorables comments
from 2016 that there's just this wide
swath of evil racist xenophobic
americans who live in the middle of the
country and they're really really
terrible awful people
and then on the right you have people
saying well if those people look at me
like that well i don't want to hang out
with those people at all and there is
somewhat of an imbalance in terms of
what people think the true threat to the
country is and that imbalance is now
kind of moving into balance what i mean
by that
is that if you look at a poll a couple
of years ago from my friend kristen
sultan sanderson what it showed is that
democrats believe the number one threat
to america
is not an economic threat it's not a
foreign policy threat it's trump voters
and you're starting to see trump voters
respond by saying okay well if you
perceive me as a threat this now makes
you a threat to me and so what this poll
shows is that a huge percentage of
americans on both sides of the aisle
really don't like people on the other
side of the aisle so to the statement
i've come to view elected officials from
the opposing party as presenting a clear
and present danger to american democracy
80 percent of biden voters at least
somewhat agree that elected officials
from the republican party present a
clear and present danger to american
democracy 84 percent of trump voters
feel the same way
are you concerned that you or someone
close to you might experience personal
loss or suffering due to the effects of
the opposing party 80 percent of biden
voters say yes 82 of trump voters say
yes
despite the us constitution's first
amendment protection of free speech some
media sources on the extreme left to
right have become so untruthful they
should be censored 78 percent of
democrats say
at least they have some sympathy for the
idea of censorship some 73 percent of
republicans say the same about left-wing
sources
of democrats say that they want to that
republicans want to eliminate the
influence of progressive values in
american life and culture 87 percent of
republicans feel the same way about
democrats
some 77 of democrats say that the
mainstream media might as well be a part
of the republican party 77 of democrats
believe the media is biased toward the
republican party which is totally crazy
of republicans believe that the
mainstream media is part of the
democratic party which is significantly
more accurate
and of course 56
of democrats believe there's no real
difference between republicans and
fascists 76 of republicans believe
there's no difference between democrats
and socialists now again i'm not going
to pretend that there is a complete
equation here because there is not the
democrats are much warmer toward
socialism than the republicans are
toward fascism there's just no question
about this it's not on a base route
level the democratic party has a lot
more crossover with socialistic ideas
about redistribution of income for
example or restrictions placed on use of
private property or even the family than
republicans have with the idea that
there ought to be complete top down
control of government in every aspect of
your life which is really the essence of
fascism fascism tends more toward the
left in that particular iteration but
it's very clear that americans bottom
line here are polarized and see people
on the other side of the political aisle
as a real threat to them
now in a second we're going to ask the
question whether that matters because i
think everybody sees that and they go
okay well that's why the country is
falling apart but there's uh some new
data suggesting that's not really why
the country is falling apart and it's
kind of fascinating and worth going into
because all of this is root level stuff
in american politics what's driving the
polarization what's driving the fact
that people are having these fraught
battles over sometimes very fringe
issues like what's driving all that we
see this poll from university of
virginia and it shows again massive
polarization the american public
democrats think republicans are fascists
republicans think democrats are
socialists and all the rest so the
question is
what sort of difference does this make
in our politics now the rote answer is
huge difference right if we don't like
each other it's going to be very
difficult for us to live together
however there is a new study that is out
from
quoted by thomas edsel who does a really
interesting column for the new york
times i know there really is an
interesting columnist at the new york
times
and he quotes a study
titled political sectarianism in america
published by 15 important scholars in
science magazine in november 2020.
the science essay argued the political
sectarianism of the public incentivizes
politicians to adopt anti-democratic
tactics when pursuing electoral or
political victories a recent experiment
shows that today a majority party
candidate in most u.s house districts
democrat or republican could get elected
despite openly violating democratic
principles like electoral fairness
checks and balances or civil liberties
right there's a study from last year
suggesting that most americans are
electing people who don't really care
about the checks and balances of
american life
however david brookman joshua khala and
sean westwood political sciences at
berkeley yale and dartmouth challenged
that science magazine article instead
they make the case in their december
2020 paper does effective polarization
undermine democratic norms or
accountability maybe not that partisan
hostility may be destructive but
attempts to moderate it will not
diminish party loyalty or tolerance for
anti-democratic changes in election law
or the decline in political
accountability in other words
it's true that partisan hostility may be
bad but even if we got rid of partisan
hostility that actually would not solve
the underlying problem which is that
many many many americans of all stripes
seem to be willing to use the government
as a club to cudgel somebody else
brookman and his co-authors agree with a
lot of the prior research that found
that effective polarization has been
growing worldwide but what they differ
with is those who take the growing
partisan hostility argument a step
further to contend that if citizens were
less effectively polarized they would be
less likely to endorse norm violation
overlook co-partisan politicians
shortcomings oppose compromise adopt
their party's views or misperceive
economic conditions
in other words this really is not being
driven by polarization the polarization
is being driven in turn by something
else
and brookman and his co-authors write
quote we find no evidence
that an exogenous decrease in effective
polarization causes a downstream
decrease in opposition to democratic
norms in other words even if we get less
polarized people still don't like
democracy anymore
we investigate the causal effects of
effective polarization on a variety of
downstream incomes in five political
domains electoral accountability
adopting one parties policy positions
support for legislative bipartisanship
support for democratic norms and
perception of objective conditions
so in other words it seems like
reducing polarization between people
making people feel better about one
another is not necessarily the answer to
the real political problem that we have
right now which is the subjection of our
political norms to withering fire
there's another article from may 2021
from a sociologist at stanford named jan
volkl and eight colleagues
in which they write there is widespread
concern that rising effective
polarization disliked for members of the
opposing party is exacerbating a range
of anti-democratic attitudes accordingly
scholars and practitioners alike have
invested great effort in developing
depolarization interventions and
successfully promising interventions
that have been have been identified that
successfully reduce effective
polarization
these efforts have mixed results we find
that the depolarization interventions
reliably reduce effective polarization
but this reduction does not reliably
translate into reduced support for
undemocratic practices on democratic
candidates or partisan violence
they conclude our findings suggest
effective polarization may not be as
problematic for democratic societies as
is widely assumed
in some the research shows interventions
can reduce both attitudinal and
behavioral indicators of effective
polarization without reducing
anti-democratic attitudes so people
could still be anti-democracy even while
they kind of like their neighbors as it
turns out this calls into question the
commonly held assumptions that
anti-democratic attitudes are downstream
consequences of effective polarization
this is really quite fascinating
research and suggests something deeper
has been going on here so what is the
deeper thing right if you don't dislike
your neighbors then why are so many of
us abandoning democratic norms why are
so many people abandoning for example
checks and balances which is clearly
happening right more and more americans
on both sides of the aisle seem to look
at federalism and say well
yeah but if we can grab the brass ring
if we can grab the top of government why
shouldn't we use that to cram down our
perspectives on a multiplicity of other
americans now the normal explanation
might be yeah i disagree with those
other americans so much and they're such
a threat to me that i need to use the
brass ring to cram down my policies to
prevent them from threatening me right
it's a battle for all right this is a
war over the government gun and if they
get it they're gonna shoot us and if we
get it we better shoot them
so that would be the suggestion that has
been made before that polarization is
what is driving the anti-democratic
tendencies and these new studies are
suggesting no that's not correct that
even if the differences are somewhat
relatively minor
people are still willing to grab the
government gun and use them to cram down
their own political points of view okay
so why is it that if what's causing all
of this movement away from checks and
balances and democratic norms and
respect for outcomes if what's driving
that is not effective polarization right
how much we feel threatened by each
other what is driving that
and the answer is i think a broad
prospective shift
on human nature that has happened in the
united states and across its parties
though not to equal extent
and a broad shift in what we think the
government was constructed for i think
people no longer understand why the
united states government was constructed
the way it was
the united states government was
constructed the way that it was by the
founding fathers because they had a
certain perception of human nature that
perception of human nature is that human
beings were inherently limited
human beings had a great capacity for
reason sure but they also human beings
had the unfortunate tendency to be venal
and self-serving and extraordinarily
ambitious
and to grab the brass ring the human
tendency was to grab the brass ring and
then to use that power against somebody
else right that was the human tendency
and if you wish to share a polity with
other people regardless of who the other
people are whether you like them or that
you don't like them
you're going to have to restrict your
own ability to use power to do what is
good see here's the thing there are two
ways to view power
and there are flip sides of the same
coin
one way is that you are grabbing power
in order to do something good
and this has been how most fascists
throughout history have justified what
they're doing they're doing something
good now the flip side of that is the
people who get the raw end of the deal
the people with the short end of the
stick to them when somebody says i'm
grabbing power to do something good very
often what that means is you're grabbing
power to do something bad to me right
you want to do something good for your
friends something good on behalf of
quote unquote society but for me
individually that's a bad thing
that the use of power inherently means
that there is somebody who is going to
be the target of the power
and so if you are grabbing power
inherently somebody else is going to be
worse off power is in fact a zero-sum
and there are very rare circumstances in
which power is not a zero-sum game
but in most political circumstances
power is a zero-sum game
it's only not a zero-sum game when you
have like overt aggression right this is
why the sort of libertarian perspective
on government is the government ought to
be used only in order to maintain
certain basic legal norms certain or to
prevent violence for example because
that is a non-zero-sum game right if
there's no violence for anybody we all
have better lives
including the people who theoretically
would be doing violence and then would
be the victim of somebody else doing
violence to them but for most of of the
things that we do as a government
somebody is going to get the short end
of the stick somebody is going to pay
the price somebody's going to foot the
bill
so what the founder said is if that's
the case then we better have
overwhelming support for anything that
we do as a federal government
particularly in order for us to make a
move right we would have subsidiary at
very local levels where you and your
friends really agree on a lot of stuff
well then you have more ability as a
local government to do what it is that
you want because everybody else who
doesn't want to live there can simply
move right if you have a very local
community you know everybody in the town
everybody in the town knows you you want
to preserve your way of life well then
you have a little bit more power under
the federal constitution you know
barring sort of certain fundamental
violations of rights like fascistic
non-voting right the the federal
government does guarantee to the states
a republican form of government
but barring extraordinarily basic rights
violations local governments can do a
lot of stuff
and then as you kind of move out as you
zoom out from the very local level to
the broader and broader level the
federal government was supposed to do
less and less because we agree on less
and less and so in order for us to do
anything we need to overcome a bunch of
obstacles and burdens in order to prove
that what we were doing was so vastly
important that it was worthy of the use
of power and so this again springs from
a vision of human nature that the
founders were grounding in both a
judeo-christian value system which
suggests that man is inherently sinful
and that man is inherently flawed and
that man also has the capacity to be
an angel but also the capacity of devil
right i mean this is directly from
federalist 51 where james madison talks
about the capacity of man to be both
angel and devil the notion was that
if men were angels no government would
be necessary and if angel and men were
devils no government would be sufficient
okay so there was that view of human
nature and then over time it seems that
the view of human nature itself shifted
and in accordance with that the view of
government shifted so in the late 19th
century mid to late 19th century there's
this movement away from a vision of
human nature as bounded to a view of
human nature as unbounded completely
malleable that that all human limits
were essentially products of their
environment and if we could just shift
the environment in any direction then
human nature would inherently change
this is one of the key components of
marxism is that human nature would
change as the economic system under
which we live changed
inevitably
and that was the the kind of vision of
the progressive view of the united
states in the early 20th century if we
can just shift the circumstances under
which people live we will create a
better form of human being there is an
innate malleability to human beings and
therefore human beings could be angels
and if human beings could be angels why
would you have to fear the government
why would you have to fear a vast broad
national government doing exactly what
it is that it wanted to do why would you
need democracy anymore you just like
really there would be no need for voting
all you would need is the right person
at the top and if that right person at
the top was doing the right thing well
then liberty would be of no consequence
because liberty of course
we we all pay homage to liberty liberty
only exists when liberty means that
something you disagree with is allowed
to happen if you believe that liberty
only extends to the things you want to
happen that's not actual liberty right
that's that's just you being your own
little dictator
and the notion of liberty is that
liberty allows for innovation liberty
allows for experimentation liberty
allows for the possibility of pluralism
as a as
the famous philosopher
isaiah berlin used to say
and the the the basic notion here is
that liberty was not only a tool but it
was a virtue
so the the
the core of liberty is disagreement the
core of liberty is that you don't have
all the answers we don't know all of the
most virtuous things that yes there are
certain baseline things that we all sort
of agree our virtuous and those can be
encoded in law
now as a society we've broken down even
those things right the argument against
liberty is that liberty has become
libertarian libertarianism and this is
the argument from the right is that
liberty went so far that it basically
tore down all the institutions that we
all used to agree upon and now we have
nothing we agree upon until we're all
falling apart so in order to reinstill a
sense of commonality we need to use the
power of government that's the argument
from the right
but that's the polarization argument
okay the the real argument that i'm
suggesting is more kind of broadly based
than that argument there's some virtue
to that argument although the virtues
don't go all that far because the
reality is that aside from kind of
resetting very very basic notions of
virtue and american life and those
virtues really are sort of relegated to
the amendments that
are made to the constitution of the
united
states virtues
the government should not really be
involved
what most people have fallen into is
this idea that the government itself is
our friend the government is quote
unquote us as barack obama suggested in
2012. well the founders never thought
the government was us we're individuals
we're families we're local communities
the government is not us but here's the
thing the minute that we as a society i
mean like pretty much everyone across
the aisle decides that the federal
government is the answer to all of our
problems
all of our questions
and the federal government ought to be
the power doing the virtuous thing not
preserving liberty not preserving the
possibility of other people disagreeing
not pursuing subsidiarity
once that happens the polarization
doesn't matter anymore all you want is
the right person in charge of the
government and this is going to lead to
an enormous amount of inherent
dissatisfaction because here's the thing
all of that's a lie it doesn't matter
who's at the top of government it's
never going to be the greatest person
it could be the greatest person and it
still wouldn't matter because we would
still have disagreements in this country
the sort of longing for an authoritarian
monarch to lead us forward out of
whatever morass we have found ourselves
in and this exists on nearly all sides
of the political out is extraordinarily
dangerous but it is an outgrowth of a
failure to understand basic human nature
in the way the founders understood basic
human nature they believed in checks and
balances because even they were blessed
with some of the great leadership of all
time and people like george washington
or john adams or thomas jefferson right
even they understood that all these
people are inherently limited and flawed
and you can't give them absolute and
ultimate power
we seem to have lost that capacity to
understand innate human flaw
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video